Charleston South Carolina is one of the
top tourist destinations on the planet
it was named best city in the world
three years ago by travel and leisure
and best city in America seven years in
a row
millions flock to see Charleston's
stunning architecture restaurants and
history until now though many don't
learn about one crucial part of the city
story Charleston was once the largest
port of entry for enslaved people into
the u.s. a few weeks ago the city held a
groundbreaking for a 100 million dollar
museum hoping to change that the sights
and sounds of a genteel Charleston are a
brutal contrast to an inescapable
reality beginning in the 17th century
and continuing until 1808 when the
Atlantic slave trade was banned by the
US government's hundreds of thousands of
people were forced onto ships and
brought here to be sold
this construction site will soon be a
museum built on the spot where many of
those enslaved people first stepped on
shore it's very remarkable to consider
what's gonna be here in the matter of I
guess a couple years
Elijah Hayward is the museum's CEO oh
when you think about what this Wharf
looked like 200 years ago yeah and then
think about what it looks like today
what goes through your mind it's really
gripping there is an amazing opportunity
that we have to tell the story of that
moment that has really impacted America
but also of what was achieved and
explored beyond that moment do you think
there are times when people forget the
suffering that took place before Joseph
Reilly was mayor of Charleston for over
four decades he'd been trying to get
this museum built for 20 years
but it wasn't until nine African
Americans were killed in 2015 at the
Emanuel AME Church that a renewed spirit
of outreach push the project forward
small cities seldom have the opportunity
to create something of great importance
to the whole country and the story told
here is an American story and it and
it's told better here than any place
the country the museum says as many as
80% of african-americans could trace an
ancestor through the port of Charleston
in one year alone 200 ships filled with
30,000 captive Africans landed here
growing up in and around this area did
you ever think something like this would
be built I think I would I had hopes
that it would be built but I think I'm
definitely living a dream right now
when completed the 31 thousand square
foot museum will feature galleries and
exhibit holes devoted to the stories of
people forced to make the trip across
the Atlantic both before and after the
United States was formed as a country
this is really meant to be a sacred
space that allows the visitor to pause
and consider what this site is all about
in a larger sense there are also plans
for a genealogical center to help people
trace their roots a sort of Ellis Island
for African Americans the South was
driven by slave labor
although opportunities to learn about
Charleston's full story have been
limited it has already been changing
I've noticed I don't hear the term slave
used I hear the term enslaved people
correct so we want to take them from
being reduced to property
to being enslaved people at McLeod
plantation in Charleston children as
young as five were forced to work
picking in-processing cotton now McLeod
is one of only two plantations in the
country whose primary focus is educating
about the history of slavery does
working at a place like this make you
hurt or does it make you hopeful makes
me hopeful Olivia Williams and John
Gardner our historical interpreters for
the plantation I tell people that on my
tour everything that you see in
Charleston down to the bricks that were
handmade by enslaved people woman they
literally built the city and keep in
mind Jocelyn was a very wealthy city
because remember the wealth of the
people was based on the number of slaves
you had the huts that how some of those
enslaved people more than a hundred and
fifty years ago are still standing as is
the gin mill some worked in so these
three fingerprints here in the bricks
the child's yes children and slaves
children who are making these bricks and
you can see it right here
this part especially when kids are
actually on the tour and I mean there
are kids who will walk up and put their
three little fingers into these spaces
and it's just such a moving experience
and this really makes it real for people
talking about the truth it hurts
sometimes but it also heals and that's
what we're trying to do here from
standpoint of getting folks
understanding back on history and why
the history we've had here in slavery
has such an impact on what we do in
United States today currently tourists
from all over choose to visit Charleston
soon they'll be able to learn about the
people who came here with no choice
Elijah Hayward says the best place to do
that is the spot where their American
stories began if you have the trauma the
pain but there's also the triumph that's
important for us to tell the story of
everything that was accomplished in
spite of that the perseverance the
ingenuity the creativity that still
continues to shape America today and
they're trying to do this project very
deliberately very carefully slowly
hopefully we'll be built within two
years but as we said in the making for
20 years or you could say 200 plus years
yes you know slavery I call it the
lasting stain on our American psyche and
for a lot of people who still question
oh what happened so long ago there has
been a lasting impact impact remains and
this is a place people can go and learn
about what some of the laws in place and
some of the lasting impact of slavery
will have on this generation those
little finger prints that's yeah that
doesn't get you
you